the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay let me just say our next topic
moving really toward machine learning
would be the last section of section of
chapter six about stochastic gradient
descent I think professor sois from
computer science is if he's able he will
take the class Friday and tell us about
STDs stochastic gradient descent
critical algorithm I mean that at a
quick look
stochastic gradient descent is does
smaller batches at a time so it's
computationally faster than pure
gradient descent but also stochastic
gradient descent is able to solve
probabilistic problems where you're
trying to minimize an expected value
instead of a function anyway it's a
important thing actually there's a
lecture at two o'clock in brain in
neuroscience about the gradient descent
algorithms and then professor Boyd is
speaking here at 4:30 this afternoon
it's overwhelming so so I'm going to
talk today about several topics that are
specific parts of optimization linear
programming is a very famous part of
optimization I don't know if you've met
it I think it's worth knowing that what
the inputs are and what's the key fact
about linear programming and of course
also what are the algorithms that's
usually what we want to know what's the
problem what are the results the
mathematical results and what are the
computational tools yeah so that's a
very established max-flow min-cut is
once
specifically linear programming that I
think maybe would serve as the best
example and then two-person games
have you met those do so would you know
what what the rules are at a two-person
zero-sum game those are the in game
theory those are the ones that are clear
everything's well established there and
in fact they're equivalent to or linear
programs so that's why those two are
coming in today and then the key fact
about two-person games and about linear
programming is duality so if there's any
word on that board it's the one in
capital letters that has mass content
okay I'm just going to start with linear
program and then move on okay so what's
a linear programming linear program it's
we're optimizing a linear cost function
so we're a minute minimizing the cost C
transpose X so that vector X is the
unknown that we're looking for and this
vector C is the cost vector so that is
c1 x1 plus plus CN xn so you can see why
it's called linear programming
the cost is linear the constraints are
also linear so the constraints on X are
set of linear equations of course I'm
not thinking of a as being a square
invertible matrix no way if it were that
would tell us what X had to be and we
our problem would be over we we have we
have n unknowns this is M by n of course
X is n by 1 that's our unknown vector
and I'm thinking that M will be smaller
than n but we do have constraints and
now comes the thing that makes linear
programming not not actually linear and
that's the constraint X greater equal
zero and I've written that as a vector
but that means that means x1 greater
equals zero on to X so it's a vector
inequality ok so we have a minimizing a
very simple function with pretty
straightforward constraints but in
equality constraints so there the
instead of these are these two together
are the constraints that and it's in
linear algebra in linear programming
language this is called the feasible set
X it's the constraint set capital okay
and in the notes right ok so let me draw
a picture to to show maybe here maybe
I'll just ask how many of you are
already familiar with linear programming
oh Allah okay so I won't labor the point
but let me just draw a picture so my
picture will be just here so that's n
equals 3 so this is the X 1 X 2 X 3
space and X greater or equal 0 means
what it means that I'm in this
one-eighth of the space right if they're
non-negative well I would say Quadrant
but I really should say octant because
it's in there's 1/8 of the full 3d space
so I'm in here and then maybe I have M
is
maybe just one constraint like so so let
me take the cost to be say X 1 plus 2 X
2 plus 5 X 3 say and the constraint I'm
just gonna have one equation X 1 plus X
2 let me make it easy make that
constraint an easy one too so this is
the this is what we're going to minimize
and that's what we have to satisfy as
well as x equals 0 so that's a plain 1
equation gives us a plane in r3 the
plane would go through what hits the
axes at 3 0 0 and so the minimum the
point has to lie on that plane and it
has to lie in the octant so that plane
is chopped off to be a triangle yeah
this is a good visualization of linear
programming and what's the conclusion
well our cost is linear so the result is
that one of these three corners is the
winner it could happen it could happen
that maybe I have equal values on those
two corners and therefore all the way
along would be also winners but when I
have a linear function it's a maximum at
the end and these are the ends those
three corners so so three zero zero zero
three zero or zero zero three are the
three corners
and one of those is the winner and the
problem is solved and forth in fact for
this case since I'm minimizing I guess
it would be that corner that
wind so let me give it a star not an x-y
s-300 cuz that oh no that three so the
value turned out to be three at the
point 3 zeros it and that's a star okay
good good good good okay what what more
do I want to do I said yes should it be
so no zero zero zero three
where's the next three is three that's
fine that gives us a chance I think that
would give me cost of 15 this would give
me a cost of 6 and that would give me
across the street
yeah it's obviously if we could
enumerate all the corners we would have
a super fast way to get the answer but
the trouble is of course that for large
values and an amount of M and n there
are exponentially many corners and we
don't want to see them all so that's
what makes linear programming take time
and need ideas so for algorithms there
are two types of algorithms two types of
codes it's all these the older as well
established ones are so one way is the
simplex method which finds a corner we
know the optimum is some one of the
corners so it can find it'll find one
corner and we'll go to the next corner
so if it starts if it starts at one of
these corners it will travel along along
an edge that lowers the cost and it has
to stop at the end because it's linear
the cost will keep going down and going
down until it bumps up into bumps into
the end point and then it can't go
further and then we would from that next
corner we would go to a next corner each
time it's like steepest descent on the
con the edges we from the first corner
we go the steepest way till we can't go
further we've hit another corner and we
and we recompute a linear algebra find
which direction is steepest from there
and and so that's the idea of the
simplex method which was invented by
dancing and and the algebra is not going
to be in today's lecture but it's
straightforward well people have to
optimize it because that's a highly
frequently used method yeah okay but
then about 20 years later maybe or 30 I
remember going to a lecture in downtown
Boston by karmarkar so I have to put his
name down our marker and he was in the
New York Times all the newspapers so it
was a big deal he had an alternative
algorithm and the exact algorithm he he
proposed hasn't survived until today but
the idea has and the idea was to go to
travel inside the feasible set and not
around the edges
so his idea because in in in here we
maybe travel down near that edge start
again travel again so its steepest
descent in the in the constraint set the
feasible set and you can use calculus
and and this idea so this is this is
interior point methods so I'll just use
the word interior that's telling us that
we're we're inside the feasible set we
don't hit come all the way to the
boundary intentionally because we want
room to move and to find derivatives
empty whose Newton's message to minimize
you see you choose a search Direction
just as all of optimization does and in
that search Direction you track it and
you come you stop before you bump into
the edge of the feasible set and then
you compute derivatives again so you can
use calculus and it it's a method that
it's an idea that the interior idea came
before car marker but he got super
publicity so it really got attention got
new thinking and new ideas came partly
from people at MIT and and these two are
now still locked in competition no one
hasn't beaten the other in in all
problems so so linear programming is
here but then for nonlinear programming
quadratic programming where the cost is
quadratic nonlinear programming semi
definite programming that's where you
have a matrix unknown a matrix
constraints those are all the more
complicated you get the more it tends to
be
interior point methods okay that's a
summary of linear programming now I'd
like to give an example and then I
haven't told you the main well let me
tell you the main fact about duality
okay
this is really and I'll write that maybe
here next to it so do a duality if
there's a dual procure LP and that dual
is going to do a maximum instead of a
minimum and the cost is is going to
involve the B from the primal problem so
this is now called the primal problem
and this is its dual so there are twin
problems they use the same data but
quite differently it's like transposing
things so so let's call the unknown Y so
for y to be the right hand side over
here is M by 1 so that's maximize that
we're subject to what are the
constraints well the cost function over
here see the cost vector goes into the
constraints and I think the greater
equal sign because obably becomes a less
or equal to sign the a gets transposed I
think that's probably probably the
constraint in the dual and it happens it
doesn't need Y we don't have y greater
equal 0 over here ok so that's a dual
problem it has a linear cost it has
linear inequality constraints it can be
solved by the simplex method you could
choose whether you solve that one or
this one because if you solve one you
solve the other
the two are closely connected and that's
the key idea of duality so maybe I'll
put the idea first of all of wheat
duality which says that the this
quantity that we're trying to maximize
we're getting it as large as possible is
always less lesser equal to any C
transpose X this is for for any this is
for any feasible allowed any can any any
X&Y that are that satisfy the
constraints remember feasible means
satisfies the constraint so in other
words this problem this maximization
problem you're trying to push this up
the minimization problem you're trying
to pull this down and it's easy to show
that the one that B transpose it's easy
to show that inequality let's do that so
B transpose Y true should be a one-line
proof so B transpose Y ok what do I do
so B transpose Y well I look over here
that's where B shows up that's X
transpose a transpose Y right because B
is ax
I'm feasible so my B is a X and for any
X this is for this is for any X that B
is going to be ax so am I good so far
and now what do I do but now I look here
I see a transpose Y sitting right in
front of me so I say well ok unless or
equal to and I guess I'm done a
transpose wise less or equal to C so I
have X transpose C C transpose X
so so equal this equals this less or
equal that I've got it weak duality is
just put together the the requirements
on x and y and you have it but word it
was this important you know if the
mathematics is right everything has to
have it please play its role and so
what's the role of X greater equal zero
there why do we need X if we just even
think of an equal one just a number Y
where do we use the fact that X is
greater or equal 0 do we do we use it
this looks so so smooth because a
transpose Y I'll write down as X
transpose C for the moment just just so
your eye says the same X transpose and
the a transpose Y is lesser equals C
where is X greater equal zero coming in
yes
yeah that's true but but I want to see
yeah so here's my point that the fact
that a transpose Y is lesser equals C
that's fine highly important but if X
was negative it would be the other way
you would you would get the other way
and you wouldn't have what you want so
we really do use the fact that X is
greater equals zero to say that I have
national equal this and then I multiply
by something positive and then I still
have less we okay good so every it's the
math is right everything does its part
and then the of course the beautiful
result the important result is that
there's strong duality just called
duality which is that at the maximum now
this is not for any x and y but this is
for this is going to be 4x
why star the winner and X star the
winner equality holds so that's to our
the maximum in the dual problem is the
same as the minimum in the primal
problem the two have met there is no
duality gap in some cooked up nonlinear
problems there could be a gap between
the maximum and the minimum but you hope
not and here this the big theorem is not
there equal a matter you push this out
push that down so that's another way to
say that duality is that this is I'm
pushing that up at some map I could
write that as a maximum of a minimum
equaling a minimum of a maximum if I
wanted so it's the duality in linear
programming was the same as one woman's
minimax theorem and his theorem applied
to two-person games so the kief the key
math result is that that is duality for
linear programming and it's gonna be
you'll see the same thing happening for
two-person games and it's a minimax
theorem or a saddle point or it's just
things come out right yep yep so just to
mention that mathematical programming of
course includes much more difficult
problems this is linear programming that
problem as you see is as a beautiful
simple theory and the paying attention
is paying attention to the algorithm
because you've got two important choices
and they both get highly developed
now okay so for game now I'm gonna turn
to well I'll do a example of max flow
equal min cut to see what and then go to
two two person game so here's a here's
an example
okay so I start with a graph yeah let me
just so this is the source this is the
sink and I'm sending flow through the
network so it's a network that I'm
sending flow through so I'm so my job is
to maximize yeah is to I'll set X at the
source to be zero and then the flow the
total flow will come into the sink so I
want to maximize X at the sink so it's
of linear programming and their
constraint so what are the constraints
every Edge has a capacity so let's see
suppose that Edge has capacity 5 let me
let me put capacities on all these edges
2 1 3 4 I'm just stabbing around here
let me say - ok I have no idea what's
happening here
but if we see the problem we'll probably
be able to solve it so so these
constraints are that the flow variable
which would be would be the why that
where I'm trying to maximize cannot to
the amount of flow just in ordinary
words the amount of flow on the edges
can't go go higher than the capacity
I could send eleven along this edge but
then I've got nowhere to send it after
that I could send well nine hundred on
that edge but obviously it would get
stuck there so the question is what's
the maximum I can send through that
network it's a classical problem and and
in fact it's it's an integer programming
problem I these are all integer
capacities I could insist on integer
flows but it's a very remarkable integer
problem because I could allow fractions
and the answer would not be it would not
involve fractions in other words if I
keep it as an integer problem then the
mathematics is definitely harder for an
integer problem what's different so so
the x's could be integers or they could
be real real numbers over here they were
real numbers I happen to get an integer
for this but if I put if I had 10
crossing planes in 15 dimensions and the
integers would be totally lost but the
point is here that if I allow real
numbers it doesn't get me any more flow
that the winning flow is an integer
anyway so it's an integer problem which
can be safely relaxed and you can safely
use simplex method or car markers method
or in the interior point method
with with non integers because in the
interior here you're not ending it
starting or ending at integers you can
do it because the the integer answer
will be in the end better okay and what
is that answer
III think I've made those capacities
like too easy too
oh I didn't do this one so so what shall
I say so I make it large like nine I
don't know okay what's the best we can
do through that through that Network
okay I can't see it from here yet what
what should I do
obviously in this simple problem I can
get anything I want pretty much to this
that far but then what can I do
let me let me even make that 19 okay so
I'm I'm not imposing much of a limit on
that edge either but these edges are
quite tight limits and these are sort of
intermediate limits well what do you
think is the most I could send through
and how would you show me that I
couldn't send more that's the key
question I want to get a bound on an
upper bound on this maximum this maximum
getting into the sink is less or equal
to and what what number would you
propose could I get a thousand through I
could start but of course I I wouldn't
tile up there I couldn't get further
what do you what do you think the best I
can do
ten I can't do more than ten how how
could I do ten twelve twelve this right
so I I see him that way can this yeah
absolutely you can split and then this
can this go here and that would would be
able to go there so I can get ten
correct can I do anything better
oh I could be sending some up this way
at the same time so I could get three
along the top
I could so this is like an auction okay
we can get up to 13 can we get so that
that was three going this way and ten
going this way is 13 and can I not
exceed 13 do I hear 40 yeah oh I've got
a lot of room for one more
so okay so 14 many kids alright do I
hear 15 if I did 12 then what would I do
I send two up here okay what am I gonna
do with them from here send them up
again and along but then now you then
the three that that I had right now what
would be back of one problem and I'm
looking for a bound to know when to quit
to know when I've optimized that's the
whole idea of duality is to find some
upper thing that I'm trying to push down
and but I can't go beyond it so so I
don't think I could get more than to see
everything has to cross this middle so
three and four night I don't think I
could
b23 somebody said 24 more than 23 I
would be very doubtful because I
couldn't get it across the middle but
then can I get 23 I doubt it
maybe 14 as best possible so how would
we show that 14 is best possible I think
if I could find so this is called the
cut a cut in this in this network so
yeah I see a cut a cut like there you
see that every bit of flow has got to
cross that cut and the total capacity
crossing is the 3 and the 1 and the 2
and the 8 which is 14 so I can't get
more than 14 through and somehow that
cut is loaded to capacity probably those
edges all all have to be fully up to
capacity then that crossed the cut so so
the cut is is a separation of edges that
go with a source and sorry nodes that go
with a source nodes that go with this
thing yeah and and then it's the edges
across the cut so I yeah is that okay
for an example so that's the duality the
maximum flow turned out to be 14 and the
minimum cut turned out to be 14 and when
those matched 14 equal 14 I know I'm
through I know I'm through because I'm
able to get 14 through and I could never
get more yeah 3 & 4 & 6 & 8 yeah okay
and of course the in a big network
the cut is the maximum cut is not going
to be visible well you couldn't you know
they would have thousands of edges you
couldn't see what you were doing but but
you could solve this problem fast
actually fast and and it's an important
in practice it's an important example a
lot of other things fit into the
max-flow min-cut example and therefore
solving it in faster than oh I didn't
even say about speed
so the simplex method almost always its
average case den Spielman who was on the
faculty here who's just terrific in this
area was maybe among the first to study
the average case so so for a for an
average choice of a and B and C instead
of making the worst choice for the worst
choice you can create a feasible set
that it has to go corner Corner corner
corner until to get to the end so the
simplex method would take exponentially
long but that's extremely rare doesn't
happen in practice I think and the
average one is polynomial so it's a fast
method on average this but and we can
show actually that was a famous result
it came from Russia that that linear
programming is in the big P versus LP
world linear programming goes with P
linear programming is a problem that can
be solved in polynomial time the simplex
method won't always do it but it can be
done yeah there came into the world
ellipsoid methods and there was a
exciting time to decide that linear
programming was actually P and not LP
yep okay so that's okay this is a case
of duality where you can understand
duality you can buy this by the state
that the flow can't exceed the capacity
of the cut so that's what duality is any
flow it has to be less Rico the capacity
of any cut their capacity being the sum
of the one so of course there are other
cuts that cut has to be crossed but
that's got three seven fourteen twenty
two capacity so it the fourteen capacity
was the was the minimum and I gave the
maximum nice isn't that nice
yeah okay so there's another world here
of two person games that also has
duality and could be expressed so let me
just talk finally today about two-person
game so the two persons are X&Y of
course what other names good they have
and there's a there's a matrix involved
this is the payoff matrix so let me take
a very simple game first so X is going
to choose one of these rows and Y is
going to choose one of these columns and
let's say payoff from x to y I like it
that way because then X whose pain is is
going to be minimizing as X was up here
and y who's collecting is going to be
maximizing as in the dual so so the
payoff well let's see I think maybe one
four to eight would be a probably a
fairly easy game to play so that so it's
a two-person game zero-sum games
some means that means all all pay what
ex pays goes to why why gets all that ex
pace there's no third party here no
lawyers involved okay so what would and
why is going to choose a column and X is
going to choose a row an X wants to make
it small and Y wants to make it big okay
so what happens in this game
what does y choose to make it big the
second column what does X choose to make
it small the first row so it's gonna be
focus in on that too because if Y keeps
choosing that column two is the best the
least that X is going to have to pay to
and he achieves that by choosing the
first row so it's a simple game that's a
saddle point it's a it's a minimum for y
in its column and it's a maximum for X
in its row but of course a matrix and
other matrix might not have such a
saddle point so that may do you see okay
with this game that would be a sort of
straightforward game where simple
strategy column two every time row one
every time is the optimal but now let me
just exchange that
so again x1 and x2 y1 and y2 or their
two column what happens now
well why kind of likes the big number
eight there so goes for the second
second column still has the bigger
numbers so Y aims for column two
but then what does X do what row does x
choose if y is in there column to the
second okay so so have I found a saddle
point where Y chooses this column X
chooses this row is that a saddle point
no because what will Y do now he sees X
choosing the second row all the time and
why sees a four very tempting for in
that row so Y is going to choose y one
the first column pretty often not all
the time because what happens if he just
if Y chooses this column all the time
then X will choose this row and only the
payoff will only be one so that things
went downhill for why they're so so this
is not a saddle point and what do we do
mixed strategy which is why we'll choose
the two columns with some probabilities
that add to one
so so the BIA so there be a third
possibility that px 1 and one I'm sorry
py 1 P times this column and 1 minus P
times the second column so that'll be P
plus 1 minus P times 8 and 4p plus
one minus P times two that's that's this
mixed column by by mixing his strategy
why we have a strategy like a third
person why three and of course the X is
going to notice after a while what what
what the strategy is this is an open
competition you you're not hiding
they're not able to hide anything you
might take well maybe Y will jump around
but that's foolishness Y is going to end
up finding the best choice of P between
0 & 1
and it will actually be between 0 & 1
because the extreme strategies of column
1 and column 2 didn't or not winners but
now X is going to do the same thing P X
1 he's gonna he or she is going to
combine those rows so so this would be P
1 for the first row and 1 sorry P oh I
better choose another number what's uh
what's another letter than P Q okay Q
okay
so so this role was a combination of
those rows so it's Q plus one minus Q
times four in the first position and
eight plus P times 8 and 1 minus the P
and Q times 8 2 times 8 and 1 minus Q
times 2
I'm sorry that I've written this too
small but but what's going to happen
what's going to determine P and Q and
solve the game well if these are equal
then what happens then X is okay with
either one doesn't X has nothing to
choose if those are equal and and Y is
staying with this mixed strategy which
gives him this third combination column
then X is good now you might say well
then X would do what it wanted but X
couldn't do what it wanted if X doesn't
stick with the optimal strategy Q for X
then Y will take advantage so that you
really the game settles down to once so
so these should be equal so when the
when those are equal what do I get IP it
looks like I have 8 minus minus 7p there
for the first one and here I have for P
minus 2 P is 2 P plus 1 did I get that
possibly right
- for P - 2 P is the to peak and always
- yeah okay so those are equal and that
tells me that 9p is 6 and P is 2/3 so
that turned out that the best strategy
for y is 2/3 on the first column which
didn't look so promising and 1/3 on the
second and by that by creating that
strategy what what do these numbers come
out to be and they're supposed to come
out equal so for P Plus so 4 times 2/3
is 8/3 plus 1 minus P is 1/3 x plus 2/3
is 10 thirds so I think that this is ten
thirds and if that one isn't ten thirds
I'm very surprised so it's 2/3
well is it for P - P yeah tell me
they're the same did I set them equal
yeah I set them equal to find peace so
they have to be the same except for
instructor mistakes which never happened
ok so those are those should be equal
then X has no choice oh no way to do
better choose these columns that he
can't choose those columns free those
roads freely because Y could take
advantage unless so this would tell this
would give the best strategy for q4 for
the sorry the best q4 for X yep
yes do you see that picture now there
could be other it could be a much bigger
matrix of course there could be other
columns suppose there was a 0 0 column
what difference what would be the effect
on the optimal strategy of how
additional column that additional option
for y3 well he wouldn't take okay so
let's make it more tempting 10 10 10
okay
oh he wouldn't tell you that right yeah
that was not so well I'm not sure what
I'm trying to say here yeah
there certainly could be there could be
rows that are columns or rows for X that
don't enter the mixed up for the optimal
mix strategy and make strategy of some
combination of strategies some
combination of pure strategies like
choose this column choose this row but
some some columns may not or rows may
not show up in the best mixture so I'll
I won't complete that partial so like
that okay so what do we do you see that
we have a duality theorem we first of
all you could write that as a linear
program the unknown is P for X you know
for y the unknown is Q for X so actually
just have one unknown in this simple
problem but for this small problem but
you have a minimization and maximization
they meet at the optimum and the duality
theorem becomes the the theorem for for
two person games linear programming
matches two person games the point about
two persons is very important three
person games are incredibly complicated
no no sería that this simple level would
would solve three person games so that's
where John Nash's Nobel Prize comes into
the picture
so his Nobel Prize was in economics
because of the wide applications but he
was able to analyze the problem of and
for functions more than four matrices of
three person or in person games so you
know the story of John Nash the the book
A Beautiful Mind and the movie A
Beautiful Mind so it's one of those
movies that involves MIT because he was
here but you can't recognize anything
about MIT the movie it's like Good Will
Hunting you're you're maybe in some
basement of some remote building but
anyway it was of course a tragic tragic
and then sure and wonderful and then
tragic again for its he had so when I
met him he was going to teach linear
algebra one section but I never
developed his that was when he was his
mental state was going downhill and he
moved to Princeton and and just stayed
and then the wonderful thing was that he
improved and then the very sad thing was
its death in a car accident on the way
home from from the Nobel Prize
so quite a story on an amazing story
yep okay so that's specific optimization
problems linear programming and
two-person games and I hope that Friday
it will be professor swath anyway the
lecture will certainly be about
stochastic gradient descent good thanks